[Música]
la fiscalía de Perú denunció al
presidente Pedro castillo postrer
indicios de lo que relacionan con una
presunta organización criminal al
interior de su gobierno que tendría como
fin controlar y enrutar procesos de
contratación para obtener ganancias
ilícitas el mandatario aseguró que se
trata de un golpe de estado en su contra
Tenemos reporte desde libros
Venezuela perdió su asiento en el
consejo de derechos humanos de la ONU la
votación que se dio de manera secreta
favoreció a chile y a Costa Rica para
llenarlos a las dos vacantes asignadas a
América Latina y el Caribe grupos de
Derechos Humanos habían presionado para
dejar por fuera este país por el
historial de represión del gobierno
ampliamos desde Caracas
éxito en el espacio la NASA logró
desviar la órbita del asteroide que fue
impactado a propósito por una nave
espacial a finales de septiembre el jefe
de la agencia espacial la calificó como
una defensora del planeta al demostrar
la capacidad humana para evitar que un
objeto cósmico destruya la vida en la
tierra
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias de
América en francés 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos en Perú porque la
Fiscales de la nación Patricia Benavides
denunció constitucionalmente al
presidente Pedro Castillo por
presuntamente a ser parte de una
organización criminal al interior del
Palacio de Gobierno que tendría como
finalidad controlar copar y direccionar
procesos de contrataciones con miras a
obtener ganancias ilícitas desde Lima
Francisco Zacarías Nos daba previamente
más detalles sobre la reacción del
presidente a este proceso
el presidente Pedro Castillo rechazó la
denuncia constitucional que realizó en
su contra ante el congreso la fiscal
general de Perú Patricia Benavides por
tres graves delitos organización
criminal colusión agravada y tráfico de
influencias Pedro Castillo denunció que
se habría iniciado la ejecución de un
golpe de estado usando el Ministerio
Público para hacer creer que lidera una
red criminal horas antes la fiscalía
realizó un allanamiento a oficinas y
domicilios de seis congresistas y además
detuvo a 5 personas relacionadas al
mandatario el gobernante afirmó que no
cederá a lo que denomina una persecución
política además prometió que no jugará
del país y se someterá a la justicia
Mientras tanto la denuncia que ha sido
presentada al parlamento debe ser
rebatida y los legisladores tendrán que
decidir si activan automáticamente un
proceso de empishment o vacancia
presidencial o si es que inician el
mecanismo de antejuicio en paralelo
abren el debate para ver si es que
derogan el artículo 17 de la
Constitución peruana que establece que
el presidente en ejercicio de funciones
sólo puede ser acusado por traición a la
patria impedir elecciones disolver el
congreso o obstaculizar el
funcionamiento del organismo electoral
algunos constitucionalistas sostienen
que la salida legal podría ser invocar a
la convención de Naciones Unidas contra
la corrupción que permite procesar a
Pedro Casio por los delitos que se le
están incriminando Venezuela quedó por
fuera del Consejo de derechos humanos de
la ONU tal como lo habían solicitado
numerosos grupos Defensores de los
Derechos Humanos que señalan al gobierno
de Nicolás maduro de la violenta
represión en el país Venezuela que se
sienta actualmente en el consejo
esperaba la reelección para llenar una
de las dos plazas vacantes para los
países de América Latina y el Caribe
pero en su lugar fueron Escogidos chile
y Costa Rica en una votación secreta
desde Caracas nuestra corresponsal
Daniela Zambrano nos entregaba
previamente los detalles
organizaciones no gubernamentales
Defensores de Derechos Humanos
celebraron que Venezuela haya salido del
Consejo de derechos humanos de la
Organización de Naciones Unidas ongs
como cepas y proveeda coinciden en que
esta es una demostración además de la
comunidad internacional tiene un
panorama más claro de cómo es la
situación de violación de Derechos
Humanos en el país políticos además se
han pronunciado y han dicho que el hecho
de que Venezuela perdiera su escaño ante
este organismo es otro revés para la
administración de Nicolás maduro luego
de que recientemente también la misión
independiente internacional de
determinación de hechos para Venezuela
de la ONU extendiera por dos años más el
periodo de investigaciones sobre
crímenes de lesa humanidad que se hayan
cometido bajo la administración de
Nicolás maduro en esta votación de la
asamblea general de la Organización de
Naciones Unidas que además fue secreta
Venezuela obtuvo sólo 88 votos mientras
que chile y Costa Rica obtuvieron 144 y
134 votos a favor respectivamente para
este nuevo periodo de
2023-2025 además las organizaciones
Defensores de Derechos Humanos coinciden
en que de ahora en adelante otros
regímenes como Irán y Cuba van a dejar
de tener un Aliado en las votaciones que
es el caso de Venezuela
y a menos 10.000 migrantes en su mayoría
venezolanos están parados en necoclí una
ciudad portuaria en la costa colombiana
cerca de Panamá esperan a que los barcos
los lleven a la frontera centroamericana
con la esperanza de llegar eventualmente
a Estados Unidos según la defensoría del
pueblo de Colombia más de 150 mil
personas han cruzado este año Un aumento
Respecto a los 134.000 migrantes
registrados en 2021
Vamos hasta México porque el senado
aprobó una medida que prohíbe las más
llamadas terapias de conversión contra
las personas de orientación sexual
diversa quienes estén relacionados de
alguna forma con estas prácticas pagarán
hasta seis años de prisión los detalles
no los entregaba previamente a nuestro
corresponsal Mario Carbonero
Así es lo que se está prohibiendo son
estas llamadas terapias de reorientación
sexual también conocidas como esfuerzos
por corregir La orientación sexual e
identidad de género
que pues lo que se está prohibiendo en
concreto son todos aquellos tratamientos
terapias servicios que busquen impedir
obstaculizar restringir suprimir anular
o menoscabar la orientación sexual la
identidad o la expresión de género que
va a ocurrir con aquellas personas que
practiquen que realicen o que financian
Estas actividades van a ser merecedores
de una pena de 2 a 6 años de prisión y
también de sanciones que van hasta las
2000 veces el valor diario de la unidad
media y actualización esto Es
aproximadamente nueve mil dólares y el
doble el doble de estas sanciones si se
trata de cuando la víctima sea menor de
edad adulto mayor o alguna persona con
discapacidad o también si hay alguna
relación de subordinación ya sea médica
laboral o académica son 11 estados los
que ya habían aprobado esta prohibición
y ahora se hace como bien lo mencionas a
nivel Federal pasará a la cámara de
diputados para su aval
el alcalde de Nueva York Erick Adams
declaró a Time Square como una zona
libre de armas a pesar de que la ley
Estatal sobre el porte fue revertida por
un juez Federal Adams quien tiene tres
armas dijo que la designación no tenía
la intención de castigar a quienes las
poseen legalmente sino que se trata de
una medida para cuidar un lugar
densamente poblado la ley autoriza a la
policía de Nueva York a implementar
controles la semana pasada un juez
Federal anuló partes de la ley de armas
del estado que planea pelar la decisión
la NASA confirmó que el impacto de su
nave Dart contra la superficie del
asteroide dimorfos ubicado a unos 11
millones de kilómetros de la tierra
consiguió desviar su trayectoria así se
constituye como la primera misión que
logra mover un cuerpo Celeste y que
podrá dar pistas de Cómo proteger al
planeta de futuros asteroides con
dirección a la tierra Manuel acá no
tiene los detalles
bonito de la capacidad de la humanidad
en el espacio por primera vez la NASA
logró cambiar la órbita de un asteroide
a millones de kilómetros de distancia
hoy la NASA confirma que dar cambió la
trayectoria del asteroide objetivo
[Música]
hace dos semanas la NASA había
confirmado que la Sonda Dark del tamaño
de una máquina expendedora había
impactado contra el asteroide de
dimorfos un cuerpo Celeste de 160
kilómetros de diámetro parecido a la
luna
pero la gran incógnita era si había
logrado modificar su trayectoria la
confirmación responde al cálculo de su
órbita sobre otro asteroide tras semanas
de observación a través de telescopios
antes del impacto de dark dimorfos tardó
11 horas y 55 minutos en órbitar su
asteroide padre más grande vivimos
y ahora el equipo confirmado que el
impacto de la nave espacial alteró la
órbita de dimorfos alrededor de didimos
en 32 minutos y por lo tanto movió con
éxito su trayectoria
con un presupuesto de 330 millones de
dólares y siete años de planeación la
misión tenía un objetivo a largo plazo
labrar el camino para desviar futuros
asteroides que podrían impactar a la
tierra
esto tiene claro ventajas para asegurar
la capacidad de la humanidad de desviar
posibles asteroides amenazantes en el
futuro también habla de lo lejos que ha
llegado nuestro programa espacial en los
últimos
ahora el camino sigue siendo largo y
Según los científicos debe haber una
cooperación global para poder
identificar las rocas espaciales que
existen y también para determinar su
composición
hasta que este Informativo en frases 24
Gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]